[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport c'est déjà le troisième
numéro de cette saison sur TV 78 au
programme aujourd'hui comme toujours des
analystes techniques des décryptages et
surtout une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau présentation en
musique de cette magnifique dream team
on commence à ma droite musique c'est un
mélange entre George Clooney et Russell
Crow George Clooney par son élégance et
de l'autre côté Russell Crow dans son
rôle pour gladiateur c'est un guerrier
dans cette émission il aime batailler
pour défendre ses idées le gladiateur
Pierre Chevalier du Rugby Club de
Versailles était avec nous
non je t'ai plus la coupe est pleine
merci pour cette présentation
pour la pour la bonne cause de
sensibiliser au dépistage pour les
maladies masculines voilà donc on marque
le coup en novembre donc il reste encore
trois semaines à peu près peaufiner
cette moustache
photo bien on continue notre tour de
table à gauche musique sa musique
résonne sur ce plateau il est
journaliste chez TV 78 c'est un charmeur
un séducteur mais c'est aussi un
journaliste expert du sport et Linois et
du football italien notre italienne
lover notre Colisée Grégory
1h merci merci beaucoup bonjour Pierre
écoutez très heureux encore une fois de
venir débattre de l'actualité sportive
et vinoise encore une fois à très riche
très heureux aussi pour les résultats
sportifs italiens avec un champion du
monde de MotoGP italien ça je m'en
réjouis il faut aussi trouver de quoi se
consoler avant une coupe du monde de
football ou il n'y aura pas l'Italie
malheureusement cette année
mais une première pour l'Italie depuis
Valentino Rossi on est content aussi en
MotoGP ce qui est bien c'est que
l'Italie brille dans tous les sports
sauf le football
on repasse de l'autre côté musique c'est
un basketteur d'exception il a joué
partout en Europe en tant que
professionnel et à jouer en ProA il a
joué à Nicosie en tur en Espagne il a
aussi joué un trap il habite dans les
Yvelines Magic Mike mocongo est avec
nous pendant une heure c'est nickel
spécialiste basket bien sûr mais pas que
pas que pas que c'est vrai que ici à
chaque fois on parle de plusieurs choses
donc ça fait toujours plaisir en tout
cas pour moi c'est je suis content de
vous retrouver ça faisait un petit
moment donc donc voilà et puis après oui
vous êtes également sur plusieurs
projets un stadium prime est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer oui effectivement
c'est vrai qu'on est dans l'air de la
digitalisation donc nous avons lancé une
plateforme digitale de recrutement dans
le monde du sport où le but c'est
vraiment connecté voilà les clubs les
joueurs et les agences sportives pour
permettre justement de dénicher les
nouveaux talents et de permettre au
corps du sport à la communauté sportive
tout simplement de bien fonctionner donc
voilà aujourd'hui ça fonctionne très
bien nous avons 8000 utilisateurs dessus
nous avons des clubs de Ligue 2 nous
avons des clubs de Pro A Pro B un peu
aussi les amateurs donc voilà moi je
pense que c'est un outil qui va
justement aider la communauté sportive à
fonctionner et ici dans la région en
Yvelines nous avons beaucoup de clubs
donc espérer que voilà les clubs les
joueurs vont pouvoir utiliser cette
plateforme là et très franchement moi en
tant que joueur j'aurais aimé avoir
cette plateforme parce que tous les
joueurs manquent de visibilité aussi
c'est pas tous les joueurs qui qui
arrive à avoir des bons agents et tout
donc voilà le message est passé en tout
cas merci on termine de l'autre côté
musique c'est la star de cette émission
notre légende vivante il aime les coups
de gueule et les 3e mi-temps toujours
avec modération bien sûr sa bonne humeur
inonde ce plateau Jean Miss avec
entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous bon
le soir à tous comment allez-vous
aujourd'hui pleine forme toujours
toujours dit je suis là c'est tout va
bien
des coups de gueule ou des 3e mi-temps
avec modération troisième mi-temps avec
deux avant et puis bon comme Pierre
aussi je suis solidaire j'ai fait la
moustache mais beaucoup plus discrète je
vous enverrai les photos aussi
au programme de l'émission à prendre le
large pour parler de la Route du Rhum le
départ n'a pas eu lieu dimanche dernier
comme prévu à cause des conditions
climatiques mais ce mercredi 9 novembre
à 14h15 précise au large de Saint-Malo
de yinois sont engagés sur ce
rendez-vous Louis Burton sur Bureau
Vallée et Eric Bellion sur comme un seul
homme powerhead Altavia à votre avis oui
Burton Eric Bellion ont-ils été perturbé
par ce report de quelques jours sur
cette route du Rhum ça devait partir
dimanche ça part finalement le mercredi
non pour vous ah oui pour vous Grégory
on va vous donner la parole Grégory un
petit duel avec allez Mike pour son
grand retour Grégory ça peut légèrement
les perturber voilà je rajoute le petit
légèrement parce que bah ils étaient
programmés pour partir dimanche le fait
de rester un peu plus sur leur bateau
alors certes ça va leur permettre de se
préparer un peu plus mais aussi de
cogiter aussi peut-être un peu plus et
j'entendais plusieurs skippers qui
témoignaient à ce propos ils ont
l'habitude d'être solitaire ils aiment
aussi cette solitude ils le disent c'est
skipper c'est d'être en mer pendant
plusieurs jours bah là le fait de se
retrouver avec beaucoup de monde au port
et bien bloqué bah il y a un petit côté
un peu bizarre alors voilà c'est pour ça
que je dis légèrement perturbé ils
étaient programmés pour partir dimanche
ça peut peut-être je vais pas dire
rabattre toutes les cartes sur la course
mais ça peut peut-être les perturber en
vue de ce départ qui a eu lieu là à la
mi-journée Mike
pondérables quand voilà quand on est
sportif ou quand on est athlète il faut
se préparer à toutes choses donc ça
aussi ça en fait partie
un grand champion comme lui il peut pas
se faire perturber justement par par le
fait que il y a eu un décalage sur le
sur le timing donc pour moi non non
franchement s'il a perdu c'est que juste
il a fait une mauvaise performance
alors pierre est-ce que Grégory vous a
convaincu ou pas du tout j'étais au
départ plus plus de la vie de Mike en
disant que chaque sportif préparait à
ajustement les reins suffisamment
solides pour pouvoir encaisser n'importe
quel un pondérable mais les arguments de
Greg m'ont fait penser à un autre un
autre argument en termes de perturbation
possible déjà les perturbations
atmosphériques parce que les conditions
qui doivent qui doivent essuyer en ce
moment sont a priori assez dentèses
qu'avec des vents à 70 km/h et donc
c'est mieux mais c'est pas quand même
concrètement c'est mieux c'est mieux ça
souffle moins que le week-end dernier
mais ça souffle fort et les
perturbations auxquelles je pensais
c'est le c'est le la polémique qui est
actuellement dans la catégorie ultime
avec justement cette cette injustice par
rapport aux règlements du bateau de
François Gabart je sais pas si vous avez
suivi ça c'est c'est un point de
règlement sur le bateau de Gabard par
rapport aux trois autres de la catégorie
ultime une histoire de winch qui est
proche ou sous le pont c'est resté
le pont bref et ça ça peut ça a pu le
week-end dernier notamment redonner un
petit peu de flan à cette à cette
histoire un peu de polémique dans un
dans un sport qui est souvent qui est
toujours été un sport de gentleman et là
pour le coup il y en a on a les quatre
les quatre de la quelques catégories
ultime Gabard d'un côté et Coville
et les deux autres
c'est pas mon échappe mais auquel je ne
pense pas qui ce qui s'échappe un peu
sur des points de règlement et pour
l'instant Gabart a pris a pu prendre le
départ donc c'est pas réglé mais le fait
de décaler le départ ça a pu attiser la
polémique genre qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
pas grand chose non non parce que bon
honnêtement pour moi vu le tag qu'ils
ont passé sur le bateau
10 et 15 jours à peu près
mise à part
une semaine
m'a mis à part mise à part effectivement
les conditions climatiques qui peuvent
qui peuvent être changés mais c'est pour
tout le monde donc pour moi le bon pour
moi ça sera pas ça pas grosse différence
après tout a été développé je peux
revenir là-dessus donc et puis en plus
il a il avait même dit qu'il a dit qu'il
avait un bateau il a il a pu travailler
dessus pendant 18 mois donc ça veut dire
que
exactement donc il a pu expérimenter ça
ils ont pu faire des ajustements avec
toute l'équipe donc voilà il était
préparé pour ça et puis il a aussi
l'expérience de cette compétition et la
participer quatre fois déjà donc 4 4
Route du Rhum il a terminé aussi 5e en
2014 il a terminé troisième du dernier
Vendée Globe donc là du palmarès quand
même c'est ça un peu plus compliqué par
contre il a terminé 9e du Vendée Globe
en 2016 deuxième Route du Rhum seulement
donc moins d'expérience peut-être ça
peut peut-être plus jouer pour Éric
Bellion à votre avis Grégory peut-être
un peu plus du coup après bon c'est vrai
il voulait prendre son temps c'est à
dire qu'il ne voulait pas aller trop
vite dans la course il avait terminé je
crois en 30 jours à peu près mais après
voilà qui a été qui a connu le sport de
haut niveau donc forcément quand on est
programmé oui on peut s'attendre à des
décalages peut-être avec un peu plus
d'inexpérience pour irrigues Lyon ça
peut le perturber et sur les conditions
climatiques ça change peu ou prenez les
choses c'est vrai que la tempête c'est
un peu améliorée mais elle est toujours
là on a une mère à 5 6 m avec bah
toujours ce passage de la Manche cette
remontée de la Manche qui est de tous
les dangers beaucoup de bateaux 138
skippers toutes catégorie confondues
donc évitez les rochers éviter de
rentrer dans l'autre bateau aussi évitez
les désagréments mais il y aura une
première nuit à mon avis assez agité
avec peut-être quelques abandons on
espère pas pour nocivelinois cette fois
je précise vise un top 15 sur ce sur
cette route du rhum et un top 5 pour
Louis Burton ou semble jouable pour pour
louer un top 5
espérer mieux ça fait ça fait souvent ça
fait longtemps qu'on en parle là moi ce
que je voulais ajouter c'est que c'est
que grosso modo ça rappelle la toute
puissance de la nature
de ce qui les attend ils n'ont plus le
choix dans la date sur le départ et sur
les sur les conditions de course en gros
et donc un décalage de quelques jours
ils auront peut-être beaucoup plus
tergiverser mais en tout cas
ils vont quand même Éric Veillon le
disait il y a trois acteurs sur cette
route du Rhum le skipper le bateau et la
météo forcément
vous êtes d'accord
logique expérience alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de rugby féminin et du phénomène
Emily Boulard superstar de la Coupe du
Monde Féminine nous parlerons également
de tennis lievinois Arthur rinderknech
est désormais numéro 1 français mais
avant de parler de ces thématique on va
parler football
[Musique]
en football la nouvelle est donc tombée
à ce lundi 7 novembre l'information a
fait l'effet d'une bombe l'entraîneur de
l'équipe du FC Versailles Youssef chibi
et mise à pied à titre conservatoire le
club l'a annoncé dans un communiqué
officiel sans préciser les raisons de sa
mise à pied coach de l'équipe depuis
juillet 2014 et artisans de la
progression du club jusqu'en national il
avait aussi emmené le club en
demi-finale de la Coupe de France
l'année dernière Vincent ewam et human
et l'ensemble du staff actuel prennent
en charge d'équipe pour la réception du
Stade briochin ce vendredi 11 novembre
deux explications possibles au club a
décidé de prendre les devants par
rapport à l'affaire Youssef chibi
celui-ci est soupçonné d'avoir filmé des
femmes nues alors insu mais il y a
également une autre histoire dans
l'histoire il y aurait des tensions avec
les dirigeants c'est bien ça Grégory
dénonce beaucoup l'omnipotence de
Youssef chibi au sein du club il y a
notamment le dirigeant Jean-Luc Arribart
ce qui selon plusieurs informations se
plaignaient de ne pas pouvoir par
exemple rentrer dans le vestiaire le
fait de rentrer dans le vestiaire
pendant les matchs et plusieurs joueurs
aussi alors d'anciens joueurs du groupe
qui était du groupe déjà l'année
dernière ce sont plein de la gestion de
Youssef chibi ça c'est les informations
révélées par nos confrères du Parisien
et aussi des cadres des cadres actuels
des anciens joueurs pro qui seraient
arrivés et qui ne seraient pas forcément
respectées on peut citer l'exemple de
jeremyland c'est Mathieu dossier vie qui
est le week-end dernier pour la le match
face à Châteauroux ont été mis tout
simplement tribune ils ont été convoqués
avec le groupe et on estime du côté de
certains joueurs qui ont été interrogés
sans révéler leur nom que des joueurs de
cet acabit là qui ont quand même un
passif professionnel qui sont là pour
apporter de l'expérience au sein du
groupe et bien de les prendre pour les
laisser en tribune c'est pas forcément
leur avoir tenu tout le respect possible
donc aussi des tensions au sein au sein
du vestiaire la question sur cette
thématique pour ou contre son départ je
rappelle que le club est actuellement
deuxième de National
oui vous êtes partagé les gens partager
oui pour vous Mike et vous oui pour vous
aussi pierre Mike alors pourquoi
pour moi c'est juste une question de
temps c'est la nature du business qui
veut ça quand on regarde c'est vrai que
ce coach là incarne un petit peu
l'évolution de ce club parce qu'il y est
depuis 2014 donc ça veut dire tout le
travail qui est amorcé depuis là
maintenant on regarde cet été le
recrutement hybride qu'ils ont eu ils
ont ramené quand même des joueurs XXL
par rapport à cette division là on parle
de jérémylène si on parle de Grégoire
Lefebvre on parle de Jordan Leborgne
donc clairement Versailles ils ont envie
de jouer le top niveau et quand je
ramène un directeur sportif comme
jean-lucaribar forcément il va arriver
avec son expertise avec ce voilà son
réseau et ce garçon-là je suis désolé je
le connais pas très bien mais je pense
pas qu'il est connu du monde Ligue 2
Ligue 1 donc à un moment donné c'est
ramener aussi un entraîneur de renommée
quelqu'un qui va apporter une lumière
justement sur Versailles et donc c'est
pour cela que je parle de la nature du
business qui un moment donné le club
évolue et on évolue avec les joueurs et
aussi avec les entraîneurs donc pour moi
c'est une décision qui est un peu
logique quand on regarde le monde du
haut niveau comment ça fonctionne en
général George voit tilter un petit peu
non parce que juste la petite parenthèse
ça c'est une réflexion qui aurait dû se
faire avant le début de la saison et
dire à cet entraîneur non nous on
préfère justement merci pour le travail
effectué mais nous on préfère prendre
quelqu'un avec un renom pour redorer
enfin pour continuer à redorer le blason
de l'équipe de Versailles et on te
remercie pour ton travail là pour moi il
y a trois choses trois choses bien
distinctes la première c'est un problème
pénal et la présomption d'innocence se
fait que on ne peut tirer aucune
conclusion il a pas été mise en examen
il est mis à pied par le club à titre
conservatoire et d'ailleurs dans un
premier temps sur cette histoire là donc
pour cela pour cela ça on le met de côté
parce que ça ça nous regarde pas et en
plus on a pas elle s'engager sur ce
terrain là la deuxième c'est un problème
relationnel avec toutes les cadres et
les dirigeants du club là c'est un peu
plus compliqué et la troisième c'est
sportif et le sportif jusqu'à présent on
peut dire que son son parcours et et
fantastique tu l'as dit ton rêve il a
amené le club depuis 2014 et même cette
année à un ayant franchi la marche
supérieur il apporte satisfaction
sportivement après la manière la manière
on dit toujours en tant qu'entraîneur
c'est pour ça que j'en parle aussi c'est
c'est le résultat qui compte qu'importe
la manière le résultat compte mais là il
y a un problème beaucoup plus profond
que le sport que le côté sportif il y a
le côté relationnel et là je crois que
si ce coupe et de son encadrement et
maintenant de son de son vestiaire ça va
être très compliqué pour lui encore une
fois même si on balaie l'histoire de de
l'histoire pénale qui qui le poursuit
mais est-ce que ça va pas permettre au
club cette fameuse histoire de pouvoir
franchir le cap et se débarrasser d'un
entraîneur qui faisait
normalement jusqu'en début de saison le
leanimité auprès de tout le monde voilà
Mike est-ce que vous voulez réagir et
après je donne la parole à Pierre bien
sûr honnêtement je dis ce qu'on vient
pas sur tous les autres points que tu as
pu énumérer mais juste sur le premier
point c'est jamais facile pour les
dirigeants ou les clubs de prendre des
décisions sur un entraîneur qui a déjà
des résultats je l'ai vécu avec Monaco
on était avec Monaco on avait un
entraîneur où on était premier du
championnat mais ils l'ont quand même
viré parce que à un moment donné quand
tu as des nouveaux dirigeants qui
arrivent ils ont une nouvelle vision et
ils ont envie de changer les gens et des
fois c'est même pas tant le coach des
fois c'est juste les personnes que eux
ils ont envie d'amener c'est pour ça je
dis la nature du business
qatari avec Antoine Cambrai qui était
parti oui oui mais qui était premier du
championnat et puis c'est après c'est un
coach aussi qui est quand même impactant
qui est quand même connu assez à
Versailles et on sait que l'ancien
président Daniel voisin qui a quitté le
club où ils ont eu un désaccord ensemble
à l'époque donc voilà on sait pas aussi
le poids qu'il a aussi au niveau du
c'est peut-être pas facile de le virer
aussi comme ça donc il y a tous ces
aspects là il avait cette demi-finale
aussi de Coupe de France exactement qui
était le meilleur parcours d'histoire du
club et même des Yvelines il faudra
appeler pour compléter ce que l'ensemble
de mes camarades et tu as été bien dit
et bien d'accord avec Mike plutôt
d'accord avec mais partagez partagez
parce que là en ce moment il faut pas se
mentir c'est un peu Dallas parce que
c'est c'est en gros du passage je pense
pour compléter ce que disait Mike et
Jean c'est aussi le passage
en marche forcée d'un monde encore
encore un petit peu amateur bon semi-pro
semi-pro avant
National 2 mais après donc là on
national
c'est du contrat c'est du contrat de
football donc s'il y a des enjeux
financiers qui sont de plus en plus
importants donc il y a un passage il y a
un passage en force et en marche forcée
du niveau amateur au niveau
professionnel genre la rappeler il y a
un télescopage de trois de trois
éléments de d'éléments sport
extra-sportif et et puis et puis
judiciaire pour pour comme Jeannot en
évacuer le côté judiciaire parce que
c'était donc c'est un livre qui avait
été levé par Le Parisien à l'époque et
pour lequel il a été gardé n'insiste pas
sur le côté judiciaire je le précise
vous l'avez rappelé aussi le le club la
soutenu où on débute saison ça n'en a
passé une raison suffisante pour le pour
le pour les vincer ça ne ça semble avoir
changé désormais parce que ça a dû peser
dans la balance et je pense que ce qui
ce qui pèse c'est l'addition de ces
trois éléments avec un
l'omnipotence la toute-puissance de
Youssef chibi dans dans le vestiaire
autour du sportif où il a écarté petit à
petit tout le monde y compris le
directeur général jean-lucaribar qui est
arrivé qui est arrivé l'année dernière
qui n'a même plus de droit de rentrer
dans le vestiaire et puis l'essentiel
c'est à dire qu'en gros il a peut-être
perdu la la confiance d'une partie de
son vestiaire et là malgré malgré un bel
arbre qui cache la forêt avec avec cette
deuxième place du National on a on a
quand même on a quand même certes des
résultats mais on a il semblerait que la
manière la manière joue quand même
beaucoup et puis là avec les deux
internationaux Aix internationaux qui
sont qui sont arrivés et qui se
retrouvent en tribune là pour Versailles
on part on parlerait d'un crime de Liège
Majesté par exemple
c'est mauvaise relation qui sont
révélées par nos confrères puisque sur
le but Victor HUG Versailles face à
Châteauroux alors la dernière journée il
a couru vers mon deepunier pour le
prendre dans ses bras il y a eu une
scène de liesse et donc c'est vrai que
c'est un peu surprenant surtout au vu
des résultats ça a été rappelé
aujourd'hui Versailles et deuxième de
national certes on est qu'à la 11e
journée mais ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
si on fige le classement Versailles
premier en Ligue 2 donc les résultats
sportifs étaient quasi parfaits la
petite tâche peut-être sur le début de
saison c'est cette élimination assez
précoce en Coupe de France même si on
savait que pareil parcours aller
jusqu'en demi finale c'était
difficilement
euh on va dire duplicable voilà je
cherche le mot et ça peut perturber les
les joueurs l'équipe là ils sont
deuxième du champion on le voit au
classement deuxième 19 points 24 points
pour Concarneau 18 pour Dunkerque on
voit que c'est quand même assez serré ce
que ça peut peut-être empêcher
Versailles de monter l'année prochaine
Jean et forcément
il y a plusieurs donc ici sur un club
qui monte qui monte et qui a des
résultats il y a un travail derrière qui
est qui est là qui est qui qui a
continué du travail effectué et qui paye
donc forcément
en changeant d'entraîneur on le sait on
en a parlé plusieurs fois sur ce plateau
il faut il faut le temps d'adaptation
avec le nouvel entraîneur qui arrive
avec ses nouvelles idées ces nouveaux
schémas de jeu sa nouvelle personnalité
et tout ça ça prend du temps
c'est ce que vous voulez
si alors moi je voilà moi je l'avais
parlé et je rejoins aussi ce que dit
Mike mais
c'est vrai mais pour moi pour moi si
c'était simplement de trouver des
excuses pour s'en séparer pour moi c'est
un peu tard c'est un peu tard non
seulement vis-à-vis de lui vis-à-vis de
lui parce que bon
ça se fait pas comme ça il y a des
résultats mais après on laisse tout le
côté dont on vient de développer mais
vis-à-vis aussi de de la marche à suivre
du club et de l'équipe parce que là
changer maintenant alors que l'équipe a
des résultats et que ça marche bien
c'est pas dit que même si quelqu'un
arrive et que c'est avec un renom qui
arrive d'un coup de baguette magique et
puis qu'il puisse continuer cette belle
cette embellisse sportive de la saison
actuelle quoi c'est ça qui qui est
dangereux
le timing sportif là il reçoit vendredi
Saint-Brieuc je crois qui fait partie
qui fait partie des très mal classés
donc là ça peut ça peut permettre de
passer quand même cette étape et et de
et de regarder devant garder devant ou
pas imagine imagine ça chute mais on va
voir si vous avez réponse dès vendredi
dès vendredi tu
les joueurs sont programmés pour ça mais
comme il a bien développé Jean c'est
c'est on parle d'un collectif on parle
d'un coach qui amène une idée avec son
staff et après des autres joueurs
comment il réagissent et puis après il y
a tout ça qu'il faut voir donc voilà des
fois ça peut être très bien marché des
fois ça peut pas marcher à Monaco ça va
être bien marcher donc maintenant voilà
c'est ça va pas marcher partout
alors il y a plusieurs noms qui
circulent il y a notamment Jean-Luc
Vasseur il a entraîné le Stade de Reims
les familles de l'Olympique Lyonnais
l'équipe féminine d'Everton il est du
coin aussi il est né à Poissy il a joué
au PSG est-ce que ça peut être un bon
profil à votre avis Grégory dans les
deux profils qui sont évoqués
effectivement
ce qui est intéressant c'est que tous
les deux ont connu le très haut niveau
puisqu'ils ont entraîné en Ligue 1 et la
chose moi pour moi que je voudrais
mettre en avant c'est qu'ils ont gagné
tous les deux le championnat de National
Frédéric hand c'est avec Bastia Jean-Luc
Vasseur c'est avec c'était lors de la
saison je me suis noté c'était en 2013
donc ils ont déjà connu ce niveau ils
ont déjà remporté des matchs à ce niveau
là et donc ils ont cette expérience qui
peut à mon avis être bénéfique pour
Versailles ça c'est la chose à souligner
après un choix entre les deux peut-être
Frédéric Hans qui est un entraîneur que
j'aime bien qui a un bon manager qui est
souvent apprécié de son vestiaire même
si ça s'est pas tout le temps bien
terminé avec les clubs respectifs dans
lesquels il est passé mais je le vois
bien à la tête d'une équipe comme
Versailles très proche aussi un de
Jean-Luc carré bar aussi c'est important
aussi d'avoir Jean-Luc Arribart proche
d'un coach oui oui parce que c'était
c'était le projet initial quand tu es
propriétaire on fait venir Jean-Luc et
c'est finalement ce que disait Mike tout
à l'heure c'est que c'est c'est cette
courbe cette courbe de d'évolution on va
dire naturel ou normal pour un club pro
avec cette approche économique et là on
commence déjà à avoir un an après cette
épopée en Coupe de France et la montée
en Nationale des noms des noms du
football du football professionnel parce
que là je parce que si on regardait dans
le rétro ne serait-ce que 5 ans
auparavant jamais on aurait pensé avoir
des entraîneurs de ce nom là comme
candidat potentiel pour le SFR et puis
un point aussi que tu as souligné par
rapport au fait que ces entraîneurs ont
déjà gagné le championnat aussi le
recrutement de Versailles qui ont pris
des joueurs qui ont l'habitude de ce
champion là donc peut-être l'expérience
si il va leur permettre de gérer cette
situation un peu compliqué pour le club
en tout cas on suivra avec attention à
les résultats de Versailles dans les
prochaines semaines au prochain match de
Versailles c'est donc ce vendredi 11
novembre contre le Stade briochin
Vincent eumann et l'ensemble du staff
actuel prennent en charge équipe pour
cette rencontre on va maintenant parler
rugby Émilie Boulard ne sera pas
championne du monde cette année les
Viennois si tu l'as avec l'équipe de
France a perdu avec ses coéquipières ce
samedi à Auckland en demi-finale de la
Coupe du monde face au néo-zélandaise le
score est terrible 25 à 24 les Français
ont raté une pénalité à une minute de la
fin la jouer aux divinoise disputera
tout de même ce samedi face au Canada le
match pour la à 3e place Émilie Boulard
n'a pas rougir de sa coupe du monde elle
fait partie des superstars de la
compétition la même a été élue MVP lors
du quart de finale face à
l'Italie Grégory
la question sur cette thématique Emile
Boulard peut-elle marquer l'histoire du
rugby français c'est fort mais c'est
fort mais bon
proto pour se prononcer
du rugby français
c'est fort comme question allez on fait
un petit duel entre les deux
spécialistes du rugby Pierre Chevalier
la question est un petit peu est un
petit peu en fatigue et forte mais j'ai
envie d'y croire parce que je l'avoue je
me suis régalé pendant cette Coupe du
Monde qui n'a pas fini
même non je dis même il y en a un qui
était à 3h du matin
c'était c'était c'était un beau moment
de rugby c'est
aussi curieux que ça puisse paraître
pour un pour un rugby même homme mais en
fait le je pense que le rugby féminin a
des a des belles heures devant lui et
Emily Boulard dans cette dans cette
décor-là a effectivement tout d'une
grande parce que elle a elle a donc elle
a 23 ans donc elle est toute jeune elle
a elle est elle a grandi dans des dans
des bons clubs donc d'abord à Chevreuse
on connaît on connaît on connaît le Club
Athlétique de Chevreuse dans le rugby
francilien et yvinois bien sûr ensuite
Chilly-Mazarin qui est sous qui est sous
les yeux les yeux bienveillants de Massy
première sélection chez les moins de 20
en 2019 et puis chez les grandes en 2021
et elle s'est tout de suite imposée des
essais donc elle évolue à l'arrière
parfois à l'aile mais c'est tout de
suite imposée elle a été même élu en
2021 c'est la marqueuse du plus bel
essai qui soit et puis elle a elle a
elle a une personnalité attachante elle
est
et elle joue bien elle joue bien au
rugby rapide velos moi ce qui me plaît
aussi dans le rugby masculin et dans le
rugby féminin c'est aussi l'évitement et
elle est capable justement de pouvoir
affoler les défenses avec avec des
crochets des crochets et c'est une c'est
une nana qu'elle a la tête bien faite
donc oui elle peut venir elle peut
devenir une grande marquer l'histoire
c'est peut-être trop tôt pour le dire
mais en tout cas elle a tout d'une
grande pour s'imposer au niveau
international et national genre
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à Pierre moi
j'ai voté côte pour tout le monde était
beau j'ai voté contre mais simplement
quand même pour je reviens pas parce que
Pierre dit il a tout à fait raison il a
très bien résumé la situation une très
belle équipe de France féminine qui ne
cesse d'évoluer et de jouer de mieux à
mieux avec ses sorties ça c'est sûr
maintenant malheureusement je dis bien
malheureusement parce que même si elle
méritante et que c'est certainement
c'est pas eu c'est pas certainement
c'est une des meilleures joueuses de la
Coupe du monde mais malheureusement
quand on voit toujours la
mais voilà c'est malheureusement pour
nous et pour elle surtout
l'équipe on en parle pas beaucoup donc
imaginez bien que la meilleure une des
meilleures joueuses de l'équipe ne va
pas marquer l'histoire du rugby parce
que elle sera pas assez médiatisée et
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris un petit
malin plaisir à mettre un petit carton
rouge parce que c'est regrettable par
rapport à la performance de cette équipe
à cette dernière Coupe du Monde Mike
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
pour ma part j'ai été quand même très
surpris par rapport à son parcours quand
on regarde d'où elle est partie c'est
vrai qu'à la gravé les échelons de
manière exponentielle et c'est une jeune
joueuse elle a l'avenir pour elle donc
voilà tout est possible maintenant le
sport je le rappelle exactement et puis
après il y a un côté aussi médiatique du
sport féminin voilà qui qui est assez
compliqué même si le sport féminin dans
l'ensemble a évolué mais mais voilà en
tout cas l'avenir pour être glorieux
pour pour elle
médiatisation qu'on parle quand même
d'une Coupe du Monde en Nouvelle-Zélande
il y avait cette demi-finale dans l'Eden
Park d'Auckland qui est quand même l'un
des stades mythiques c'est vrai que elle
demandait on l'avait interviewé juste
avant son départ pour la
Nouvelle-Zélande elle espérait que cette
coupe du monde puisse mettre en lumière
un peu plus cette équipe de France de
rugby féminin dont on n'a pas beaucoup
parlé même si les matchs ont été
diffusés sur sur TF1 donc il y avait
quand même les matchs qui étaient
diffusés en clair et on pouvait les
regarder bien heureusement et fort
heureusement moi j'ai dit j'étais un peu
entre les deux je sais pas si elle peut
marquer l'histoire du rugby féminin
c'est un peu trop tôt pour pour se
prononcer mais je rejoins les camarades
sur la progression fulgurante pour une
chose qui a commencé vraiment à jouer on
va dire sérieusement au rugby qui à
partir du lycée donc c'est vrai qu'elle
a un parcours qui a été rapide assez
rapidement fait sélectionné dans les
équipes de France de jeunes a été dans
un très bon club formateur qui est
Chilly-Mazarin et maintenant c'est une
nouvelle étape de Sakara l'équipe de
France et aussi Blagnac ou elle est
partie à l'intersaison donc on va suivre
bien sûr ça avec attention maintenant de
dire qu'elle va marquer l'histoire du
rugby français attendons encore avant de
se prononcer un peu sceptique pour
l'instant je suis pas sceptique mais je
un peu mitigé un peu mitigé on continue
à parler de rugby mais plus précisément
de la Coupe du monde de rugby 2023 en
France c'est officiel le stade omnisport
de Croatie sur scène sera le camp de
base de l'équipe officielle de l'équipe
des îles Tonga depuis plusieurs années
le site a vu défiler les sélections
nationales il y a eu l'équipe de Russie
pour l'Euro 2016 l'équipe de Liverpool
pour la finale de la Ligue des Champions
ou des équipes féminines pendant la
coupe du monde de football mais le City
Vinois ne sera pas le seul concerné par
la Coupe du Monde 2023 Versailles va
également accueillir le Pays de Galles
la question sur cette thématique les
Yvelines sont-elles une terre de rugby
et un finalement
fière de sport
votre avis Pierre Chevalier si j'avais
mis ça je pense que je pense que on
aurait voulu on me raconte traité d'un
conséquent oui oui les Yvelines sont une
terre de rugby
multisports on en parle suffisamment
souvent sur ce plateau mais en fait
c'est simplement regarder le nombre de
clubs qu'il y a les écoles de rugby la
formation les équipes les équipes
amateurs au plus haut niveau alors au
plus haut niveau certes c'est le c'est
la fédérale 2 avec avec plaisir à
Versailles
Maisons-Laffitte en fédéral 3 et après
il y a toute une corde de club de clubs
dans les niveaux régionaux mais oui
générale 3 aussi donc il y a déjà il y a
beaucoup de clubs donc en numérique ce
sont des écoles de rugby et des groupes
seniors qui sont importants on y joue
bien au rugby on y vit bien rugby on
parle souvent de convivialité donc oui
on est bien placé pour pour le dire que
que ça vit bien dans les Yvelines et
c'est ça n'est pas un hasard total si le
Pays de Galles choisit un camp de base
assez central assez assez agréable parce
que parce que pour le coup la ville de
Versailles pour une équipe de rugby qui
va y passer un mois à peu près un mois
c'est
d'être bien installé sportivement mais
aussi dans la vie de tous les jours ils
vont être ils vont être très bien
traités dans la ville de Versailles les
Tongas Croissy c'est c'est au bord de la
Seine ça va être aussi ça va être un
endroit très bucolique mais aussi
technique pour pouvoir bosser pendant
les matchs de poule donc oui oui les
Yvelines les Yvelines s'installent de
plus en plus comme une ville de rugby et
c'est reconnue maintenant au niveau
international mettons le gars
Croissy-sur-Seine que vous en pensez
Mike bonne nouvelle pour les Yvelines
oui monsieur monsieur tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est au sport de notre région
on est forcément content pour ça donc
s'il a bien développé tous les aspects
moi je suis pas un spécialiste mais
c'est vrai qu'on t'écoute en parler
j'apprends aussi beaucoup et c'est vrai
que c'est formidable pour la région
Jean les Tongas Croatie le Pays de
Galles à Versailles forcément deux
bonnes nouvelles parce que les Tongas
c'est quand même une belle équipe c'est
une belle équipe et c'est la preuve
pierre la pierre la souligné très bien
mais c'est la preuve que les Yvelines
est
une région
en vie et envieuse puisque des grandes
équipes viennent s'y installer lors des
grandes compétitions
les Tonga n'ont jamais passé le stade
des poules vous pensez qu'ils peuvent le
faire
sportivement on sait bien comment se
passe les coupes du monde
pas si lointain que attention
on s'en réjouit on s'en réjouit
forcément d'avoir des équipes pour cette
coupe du monde qui se déroulera en
France qui seront présentes sur le
territoire des Yvelines comme on se
réjouit d'avoir des sites olympiques des
on parlait tout à l'heure de foot
pendant l'Euro 2016 souvent le
territoire est vivant est choisi pour sa
proximité avec Paris moi aussi je pense
pour la qualité des installations et ça
bien sûr on peut que s'en réjouir il
faut toujours le souligner on a beau
département quand même alors on va
maintenant parler de basket je vois
sourire Mike vos combos vous attendez ça
avec impatience en plus le début de
l'émission on va parler de quelqu'un
qu'on connaît très bien sur ce plateau
son nom Victor weembanyama 18 ans
ivin why 2 m combien 19 2m21 rien que ça
il a grandi depuis
tout petit à 2 m 15
il a été appelé par la première fois en
équipe de France senior il devrait faire
ses débuts contre la Lituanie ce
vendredi 11 novembre à 18h30 l'intérieur
de Boulogne Levallois aura donc sa
première sélection la première d'une
très longue série à mon avis une étape
de plus après un excellent début de
saison en club la question sur cette
thématique peut-il déjà devenir le
pilier de cette équipe de France oui ou
non peut-il déjà peut-il déjà devenir
un le pilier le pilier
on va donner la parole aux spécialistes
par contre un Mike non non mais très
honnêtement on peut pas dire
qu'aujourd'hui il va devenir le pilier
de l'équipe de France parce que voilà
c'est une autre compétition c'est un
niveau qui est encore très très élevé
même si c'est vrai qu'il nous a surpris
sur ce enfin pas surpris mais son
évolution par rapport à ce début de
saison et quand même exceptionnel il a
doublé tous ces chiffres au niveau point
rebond et tout donc voilà mais je pense
que dans un avenir
proche ou lointain ça sera justement un
des joueurs majeurs de l'équipe de
France il a que 18 ans c'est vrai qu'il
y a encore des tauliers comme non dodo
colo et vin de Fournier rue diegobert
mais voilà ça va être une bonne
expérience pour lui et justement je
l'avais dit sur le plateau que c'était
une bonne décision pour Victor Hugo de
venir à Paris pour la simple raison que
ce genre de joueurs de demain de 21
arrive à maturation tardivement donc
c'était bien pour lui de se reposer de
pas faire trois matchs à glacevel de
prendre le temps de soigner son corps de
se renforcer d'apprendre les rouages du
haut niveau avec Vincent Collet qui est
référencé comme un des meilleurs
coefficients en France et en plus il est
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France donc
pour moi voilà c'était une décision très
très sage et autour de son entourage
c'était bien vu genre qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez donc il avait vu grandir
[Musique]
moi ce que je vois c'est que c'est une
explosion phénoménale
mais est-ce qu'il peut devenir le pilier
déjà
c'est pour ça que je suis un peu mitigé
parce que le pilier on ne sait pas ce
que ce que va devenir ce joueur mais
comme Mike la souligné il y a quand même
des il y a quand même des patrons des
gens qui sont en équipe de France et qui
ont de l'expérience en plus lui arrive
il a 18 ans il va apporter il va
apporter sa pierre à l'édifice et
certainement que certainement que ça
deviendra ça deviendra un des éléments
majeurs de de l'équipe de France mais de
là à dire parce qu'il a vraiment il a
vraiment quand même une une ascendance
énorme il fait chaque sortie il sait il
s'est un petit peu plus enrobé donc il a
dû il a dû quand même travailler un peu
il doit travailler énormément au niveau
de la muscu et puis attention c'est
sorti son phénoménal
sunny aussi il a des statistiques il
explosent il explose donc après
c'est le niveau international niveau
international attention Méphisto c'est
pas pareil c'est pas pareil il faut
faire attention d'ailleurs il fait
attention dans son interview qu'il a
donné à la presse hier il disait qu'il
ne savait pas au niveau international ce
qui pouvait donner pour l'instant voilà
en tout cas ça c'est le maquillage au
niveau des médias on affiche pas
forcément nos ambitions devant les
médias parce qu'après derrière c'est
disproportionné donc
très grande maturité de la part de
Victor webanyamar les journalistes ont
attendu de pied ferme pendant toute la
journée et lui ce qu'il a dit en
arrivant dans la salle de presse il a
dit heureusement que je ne suis pas
Christopher tout simplement voilà donc
on avec un petit sourire donc il est
assez à l'aise avec les médias
exactement il est programmé pour ça de
toute façon
trop tôt pour pouvoir dire qu'il sera le
pilier alors un pilier sans doute déjà
non on est tous d'accord pour dire que
c'est c'est encore trop tôt et puis
surtout ça serait pas lui rendre service
finalement de l'huile de lui attribuer
ce rôle là on en parle sous depuis
tellement longtemps en fait en gros de
cette de cette visibilité vraiment de
d'évoluer tranquillement naturellement
mais il y a quand même moi un point qui
me qui me marque et qui me fait dire
qu'il deviendra un voir le pilier de
l'équipe de France c'est son aisance son
aisance technique finalement malgré sa
taille ça peut au basket cette taille-là
est un ma priori en avantage mais ça
peut être aussi un inconvénient sur sur
le sur l'aisance corporelle et sur
l'ordre de ces derniers sortis dernière
sortie avec les Metz je l'ai vu shooter
à trois points je l'ai vu dribbler mais
dribbler pour un intérieur comme ça qui
qui devrait par sa taille non pas par sa
carrure jouer pivot mais dribbler
dribbler et même s'amuser avec ses
adversaires et shooter à trois points de
manière absolument
facile facile et déconcertante de
d'aisance donc ça ce côté technique du
bonhomme qui continue à grandir en plus
c'est d'un bon signe et des bonnes des
bonnes raisons d'espérer qu'ils
deviennent un des personnages
incontournables 5 majeurs français c'est
du jamais vu Mike oui franchement c'est
du jamais vu déjà au niveau médiatique
on peut le comparer un peu LeBron James
qui était parti depuis High School faut
pas oublier que la Fédération Française
de BasketBall a signé un accord avec la
Ligue et la NBA pour que tous les matchs
de Victor hugoïa soient diffusés aux
États-Unis il faut se réjouir de ça en
étant français de voir un joueur
français comme ça à ce niveau là il faut
le pousser et puis après c'est un joueur
générationnel un joueur moderne 2 M21 il
peut tirer comme Steph curry il peut
dribbler comme cayourving il peut
contrer comme rudy Gobert parce que
limite comme ils disent les Américains
pour lui donc il faut juste espérer
qu'ils sont en bonne santé je pense
qu'il a la tête là où il faut un
entourage sain et c'est ça le plus
important pour le voir il y a l'équipe
de France qui apparaît à l'écran il y a
quand même du beau monde dans cette
équipe de France saint-grégory c'est
pour ça que dire que déjà il peut
devenir un pilier l'équipe de France
avant même son premier match sa première
sélection officielle avec l'équipe de
France c'est un peu anticipé Michael
laissons les jeunes grandir
tranquillement je la répète à chaque je
le répète dans cette émission après ce
qui est sûr c'est que on le disait on le
répète chacune de ces sorties et scrutés
avec attention il a fait des matchs de
gala aux États-Unis très récemment c'est
son début de saison avec Boulogne
Levallois ou c'est vrai moi j'étais un
peu mitigé mais il a rejoint Vincent
Collet effectivement je pense mais mon
convaincu finalement sur par la suite
que d'abord rejoindre cette équipe
c'était c'était une bonne décision c'est
une nouvelle étape l'équipe de France
c'est une étape supplémentaire dans sa
progression il est très jeune il a 18
ans ce sera une nouvelle étape quand il
ira en NBA mais comme le disait Jean
aussi passer du basket de club et du
sport en club au sport en sélection
c'est deux choses différentes donc
laissons lui le temps de faire ses
preuves et de grandir tranquillement
puis ça va dépendre de la draft drafting
l'année prochaine savoir en gros où il
va atterrir mais je pense qu'ils vont se
l'arracher les franchises américaines
numéro 1 de la draft qui joue pas il
sera un numéro 1 après j'ai juste pas
envie que au fil de son évolution qui
deviennent pas un peu là je parle à nos
joueurs mais Mbappé aujourd'hui qui
devient un joueur un peu égocent de
rester un petit peu intelligent comme
une en train de le faire d'évoluer de
mettre l'équipe toujours en avant et
tout ça c'est très important justement
pour évoluer je veux emmener de la
fraîcheur dans une équipe de France qui
fonctionne très bien exactement moi je
pense que ça c'est une preuve d'humilité
et puis c'est un garçon qui sait que
tout le monde est derrière lui mais il
se met au service du collectif voilà il
arrive tranquillement il veut faire son
il veut faire ses débuts avec ses
coéquipiers donc moi je pense que c'est
très louable en tant en termes de d'état
d'esprit en tout cas on le souhaite bon
courage
on continue évidemment sur Victor web
animal on lui souhaite bon courage pour
ses débuts en plus on passe maintenant
notre page débat
on va maintenant passer à notre volet du
jour avec vous Grégory le moment le plus
intense de cette émission alors de quoi
allez-vous nous parler une fois n'est
pas coutume on va commencer cette
envolée avec une petite séquence je me
suis replongé dans les archives de TV 78
rassurez-vous je suis pas allé bien loin
je suis allé en 2018 et vous faisiez la
connaissance à l'époque Michael de
quelqu'un regardez
l'ambiance est détendue pourtant dans
quelques heures Florian lacate et Arthur
rinderkness joueront sur les cours de
Roland-Garros ces deux Yvelines moi de
22 ans bénéficié d'une invitation pour
jouer sur son tournoi du Grand Chelem en
double une première pour un joueur du
département depuis un certain Michael
yodra on est très chanceux d'avoir eu
cette Walker en double et
je suis vraiment impatient de vivre
pleinement cette expérience de mon
premier Roland Garros c'est génial c'est
top
avec Arthur ont forcément aussi
attendait pas forcément mais c'est
vraiment un super cadeau et on va
essayer de se concentrer à 100% pour
pour en tirer le meilleur
l'action de Michel et le midrot avec
Arthur Rinder cneche me souviens qu'à
l'époque on avait tous du mal à
prononcer son nom c'est peut-être encore
le cas pas facile il faut le dire c'est
ça soyez honnête mais vous l'avez
rencontré pour la première fois est-ce
que vous aviez imaginé la suite des
événements moi je pensais plutôt que ça
serait Florian lacat qui a les percer
finalement c'est Arthur et nochness qui
qui perce j'étais pas forcément voilà
à percer c'est moins collant plaisir
parce que le aujourd'hui
les numéros du tennis français c'est le
premier joueur classé au classement ATP
alors c'était difficile de s'attendre à
Paris parcours on remonte un petit peu
le fil de sa jeune carrière puisqu'il
est rentré sur le circuit professionnel
et la tout récemment en 2018 on disait
c'était une première participation donc
à Roland-Garros c'était en double pour
la petite anecdote le saint-germain-nois
aux côtés de Florian lacatte avait été
éliminé au premier tour et ça a été que
le premier acte on peut le dire d'une
ascension qui a été fulgurante lui le
joueur arrivé sur le Tarn dans le
circuit professionnel à seulement 25 ans
un parcours atypique avec une étape
importante pour moi c'est ces études à
l'université du Texas aux États-Unis où
il a pu perfectionner son jeu et
développer peut-être un profil presque
unique dans l'Hexagone depuis
l'ascension est incroyable en 2020
Arthur indercle passe de la millième
place mondiale à la 160e place mondiale
rien que ça grâce notamment à deux
victoires en tournoi Challenger Rennes
et kalgo et Calgary il y a aussi cette
première participation en simple un
tournoi du Grand Chelem c'était ta
Roland Garros 2021 ça a été ensuite la
l'année de la reconnaissance une
victoire au Challenger d'Istanbul il a
atteint un deuxième tour également du
tournoi du Grand Chelem c'était à l'US
Open une première dans sa carrière et sa
carrière et une autre première j'en perd
mes mots c'est une sélection une
première sélection en équipe de France
de Coupe Davis c'est livre noir rentre
même cette année-là dans le top 100
mondial cette année en 2022
elle l'ascension se poursuit ça a
commencé fort il faut le dire une
première finale dans un tournoi ATP il
brillait jusque là dans des tournois
challenger première finale à ATP c'est à
Adélaïde en Australie derrière Arthur
arrive confiance à l'Open d'Australie il
passe le premier tour de fort-bel
manières avant d'abandonner car il a été
handicapé par une blessure au poignet
une blessure qui va l'handicaper pendant
quelques semaines mais le tennisman ne
lâche rien en mai il empoche le
quatrième titre de sa carrière
professionnelle au tournoi challenger de
Poznan et pour couronner son abnégation
la tour récemment et à bénéficié d'une
welcard au tournoi ATP de Paris bercel
alors Arthur hinderkness et donc
aujourd'hui mercredi 9 novembre on sait
que ça peut évoluer très vite dans le
monde du tennis le 44e joueur mondial ce
qui fait de lui le numéro 1 français
devant Adrian manarino 48e ou encore
Corentin Moutet également fils
respectivement 51e et 52e effectivement
je le cite le petit garçon a bien grandi
il a tenu à le souligner sur son compte
Twitter le
[Musique]
félicitations félicitations
félicitations
[Rires]
non c'est vrai que c'est une belle
ascension pour un garçon qui est revenu
déjà depuis 4 ans des États-Unis
de le voir performer à ce niveau là
c'est exceptionnel on voit qu'il y a il
y a une stratégie qui est mis en place
par son coach Sébastien Viller et il
branche pas trop c'est un gars qui a
l'air humble ils feront aussi les
gestions après les échelons il prend il
se prend pas la tête donc je pense que
pour lui là l'étape en étant en
compétiteur comme il est c'est forcément
essayer de faire mieux peut-être au
niveau au classement mondial mais en
tout cas c'est vrai que c'est super ce
qu'il est en train de faire
ce que vous en pensez oui bien sûr qu'il
avait vu tout petit aussi
non mais c'est vrai que
je crois que Grégory a été complet
félicitations même si c'est un boulot
mais c'est vrai on va pas bouder il est
44e joueur mondial c'est bien et on
espère on espère que c'est le le nouveau
joueur du tennis français qui va
redonner de l'élan à notre tennis qui
est bien terne depuis quand même
quelques années où on a plus personne
qui ne brille oui ils sont éliminés
sportivement ou c'est la blessure il se
retrace sur la blessure donc là on est
pas bien du tout alors numéro 1 français
il pouvait que passer le ventre tout le
monde puisqu'il y a plus personne donc
ça c'est pas ce qui me sur qui
m'impressionne le plus même si c'est
très très bien que je le félicite mais
c'est surtout sa 44e place mondiale qui
est importante et qui sur laquelle il
faut vraiment qui qui travaille pour
gravir les échelons et aller titiller le
les 10 premiers les 10 premiers mondiaux
quoi qu'on est on est une fois de plus
un joueur français qui qui représente
notre tennis national
des Top 20 mondiaux
d'en parler mais heureusement qu'il y a
des filles dans le tennis français
simplement de dire que c'est quand on
quand on regarde là aussi dans le
rétroviseur c'est que et qu'on compare
les différents pays européens ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu alors on a
rappelé l'historique un bon jeune un bon
jeune là on est revenu je sais pas
en arrière bon c'était c'était un jeune
prometteur il m'avait même de un il est
passé complètement à l'autre il est
passé complètement à la trappe et quand
on quand on regarde ça ça fait très
longtemps très longtemps qu'on a pas eu
vraiment de mon jeune qui a duré en fait
c'est surtout ça qui a duré la mineur on
lui souhaite refrain vous refera des
refrains des des ATP ou des ou des
grands Chelem on lui sourit dedans des
coups là-dedans mais
surpris de son parcours d'ailleurs
exactement pour quelqu'un qui a connu le
tennis un peu tard mais c'est peut-être
ça aussi la fraîcheur c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être là aussi la raison de la
raison de son succès mais quand on
regarde le sache que runes qui gagne qui
gagne à Bercy la semaine dernière
c'est un tout jeune tout jeune qui qui
montre des photos de lui avec Djokovic
et quasiment moins de 10 ans plus tard
il le bat il le bat en finale en finale
la Bercy en France on attend depuis ça
va faire 40 ans qu'on attend le
successeur de Yannick Noah Roland Garros
bon ça pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
trouvé les clés quelle année
93 alors on va continuer à parler de
tennis avant la fin de cette émission et
d'une magnifique performance vous l'avez
dit précédemment cette ivinoise est tout
en haut du monde Caroline Garcia qui est
né à Saint-Germain-en-Laye est devenu la
deuxième française de l'histoire après
Amélie Mauresmo avoir remporté le Master
s'est imposé à forte force aux
États-Unis face à la biélorus Arina
sabalenca le score 7,6-4 la France
attendait cela depuis 17 ans la question
sur ce thème Caroline Garcia fait-elle
désormais partie du gratin du tennis
français tennis féminin français 4e
mais avant de parler de sa performance
il faut quand même parler de sa force de
résilience il faut pas oublier que c'est
une joueuse quand même depuis 4 ans et
la traversée de moments difficiles
perdition de tennis crise de confiance
des problèmes physiques donc elle a
continué à croire en elle et finalement
de de revenir à ce niveau c'est comme
une renaissance pour moi pour elle c'est
une résurrection carrément de revenir et
performer justement à ce niveau là vous
l'avez dit en plus le tennis français
qui se porte pas forcément bien
chapeau à elle flying carreau comme on
la surnomme et on peut ce que se réjouir
de cette performance là ce genre de de
joueuse qu'elle soit elle ou améliorer
mon resmo ou Yannick Noah il faudrait
leur dresser des statuts des stades à
leur nom parce que exceptionnel ce
qu'ils font
moi ce que je trouve avec Caroline
Garcia un marquis l'histoire ça c'est
une chose on peut pas on peut pas le
café
forcément
là pour le coup oui parce que
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
exploit c'est très bien mais c'est quand
même ce qui est un peu plus c'est que
avec quand même de mémoire quelques
problèmes de de relationnel avec son
père qui l'entraînait pendant une
dizaine d'années je crois de mémoire et
qu'elle a changé il est pas très très
longtemps non c'est 2020 je sais pas
j'ai pas les dates il me semble que s'il
y a pas très très longtemps qu'avait
qu'elle n'est plus
sous on va dire sous sous la coupe
sportive de son père qui devait un petit
peu l'étouffé il est toujours là mais
c'est plus lui et son entraîneur
officiel en tout cas elle a su rebondir
elle a su se remettre en question parce
qu'à un moment donné elle avait quand
même des petits des petits moments où
elle a bouder un peu elle faisait un peu
sa star et un truc pour moi elle avait
un très très mauvais état d'esprit là
elle est revenue une sportive accomplie
une compétitrice hors pair avec le
résultat magnifique à la clé donc bravo
félicitations et surtout qu'elle
continue qu'elle continue parce que je
pense que c'est pas fini elle est elle
est pas vieille donc elle vient elle
vient tout juste d'avoir 29 ans 29 ans
29 novembre
les phases et les dates de cette
championne qui me qui me marque
notamment de ton en reparler un petit
peu c'est ces apparitions en Coupe Davis
c'était pas forcément très très bien
passé il y a quelques années d'un point
de vue d'un point de vue relationnel
donc dans dans la représentation de la
France en équipe de France où en
individuel pour la France ça a pas
toujours été rose pour elle là cette
saison là elle la démarre en janvier
elle a connu un démarrage catastrophique
catastrophique en fin d'année 2021 elle
démarre en gros en gros en janvier elle
commence à avoir quelques résultats elle
commence à bien jouer et je suis
d'accord avec Mike c'est cette
résilience qui est quand même ces
phénomène ce qu'elle a fait gagner le
master il y a il y a tout le gratin et
donc oui elle en fait partie parce peut
désormais les quatrième mondiale avec
cette victoire quatrième mondiale on
vient d'en parler chez les hommes c'est
10 fois 10 fois derrière à 44e avec
anderlech et c'est déjà une belle perf
donc la quatrième mondiale chez les
dames c'est phénoménal et ce qu'elle a
ce qu'elle a réalisé ça fait écho aussi
à ce que disait jaloux tout à l'heure
sur le rugby c'est là aussi on a un
petit peu plus de médiatisation au
tennis au rugby féminin mais quelqu'un
qui remporte le une championne française
qui remporte le master on en fait pas
non plus des caisses on en parle pas de
manière assez incroyable c'est plus sur
les réseaux sociaux dans la presse il y
a pas eu de une dans les dans nos dans
nos Bibles dans nos Bibles sportives
les réseaux sociaux l'ont mis en avant
alors ok il y a le décalage horaire mais
quand même ce qu'elle a réalisé chapeau
place mondiale 4 c'est un peu le chiffre
qu'il a caractérise sur sur cette saison
parce que c'est une saison
exceptionnelle qui avait mal démarré il
y a eu un été fantastique avec des
titres remportés au final c'est son 4e
titre sur sur cette saison il pas dans
l'histoire du tennis français au total
sur 12 qu'elle a remporté au total mais
sur une saison il y a que Amélie
Mauresmo qui a fait mieux avec 5 titres
donc d'une certaine manière elle est
déjà rentrée dans ce gratin du tennis
français vous êtes satisfait c'est
performant bien sûr c'est déjà
malheureusement la fin de cette émission
va terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de Yannick Noah justement
l'ancien tennisman dernier vainqueur
français à Roland-Garros le secret c'est
de vivre au jour le jour ici et
maintenant et de bien hiérarchiser les
objectifs il y a la montagne à gravir et
les étapes pour arriver au sommet ces
étapes sont votre quotidien je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]